I think it is very hard to win in the
long long term without the best products
most of the founders that I have spent a
lot of time with they've gone on to be
super successful spent a very long time
on their idea when a lot of other people
would have given up one of the things
that someone once told me was most
impressive about Mark Zuckerberg is not
that he hired pretty well
because a lot of founders do that but
that he fired well and he could fire
people quickly they weren't working out
he's an American entrepreneur programmer
venture capitalist and blogger he's the
president of Y Combinator he's a
personal investor into many companies
such as Airbnb stripe and Pinterest he
stand Alton and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number one
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the fact
and as always guys as you're watching
the video to be here something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it to other people to be
inspired as well also as you are writing
something down it's much more likely to
stick in your head to enjoy
yeah I think if you don't actually
believe what you're doing is really
important if you don't derive
satisfaction from what you're doing then
you will not be able to sustain all of
the bad things that happen an incredibly
long period of time that the bad things
happen over and so the only motivation
that I have seen work for people over a
long period of time is enjoyment and
what they're doing in an intense belief
that it matters and ideally liking the
people that they go to work with every
day on but the I think the reasons that
a lot of people and by the way it's
totally cool when people start off
saying well I want to make money or I
want to be famous I think a lot of
people start that way and I don't like
to admit it but pretty quickly or least
in the first few years I think a lot of
people find a deeper mission for why
they do what they do and that that
drives them in for the rest of the time
they work but I think if you look at the
the companies that endure over decades
they tend to win on product it is true
that it is critical to get sales and
marketing right because without that you
just don't get the flywheel going but I
you know like the most valuable tech
company in the world is Apple and I
think they may like just the best
products across the board I don't know
if Google is still number two but I
think like Google search dominates
everything else and also like most out
like Gmail and Google Maps dominate the
respective products I think Airbnb one
on product I think that Facebook
although they came late to the game had
like the best product by far and they've
and they've managed to expand that so I
think I don't ever try to let people off
the hook for sales and marketing because
if you build the best product in the
world and don't get anyone to use it
that still kind of sucks but the I think
it is very hard to win in the long long
term without the best product I think
that you can get acquired two years in
because you had a really good like press
or marketing strategy but that does not
that is not how you create sort of
enduring value eventually sort of these
things converge ignore people telling
your idea is bad they may be right but
the only way to know is to actually
build it out and I think the thing that
works about Silicon Valley this
different than Mexico City or almost
anywhere else in the world is the
default response if someone says hey I'm
going to start a startup here's my idea
the default response is to be excited
and think like oh why might that work
and in most of the rest of the world the
default response when you tell them on
your idea is to say oh that's not going
to work and this is really toxic for
start-up because you have to believe in
yourself and and the good ideas because
they sound like that ideas are so
fragile and so killable is that you have
to be really careful to insulate
yourself against this so knowing when to
quit and knowing when to give up on
something is there's no perfect answer
to that but it's really challenging to
even get that approximately correct I
think most people give up on things way
too early so the mistake that most
people make is they try something it
does not immediately work you see this
particularly in young entrepreneurs it
does not immediately work after seven
weeks they say you know what I tried
this thing it's just not meant to be and
I have too many other projects so they
immediately give up and you kind of you
know the satirical version of this is
people that are 23 and it started 14
startups because they give up on
everyone before I could ever possibly
successful these things are really hard
they take a very long time there are a
lot of critics there are a lot of people
who say this thing sucks it's going to
fail it's really stupid and then also
there's like what YC we call the trough
of sorrow where no one even bothers to
say it sucks because no one cares at all
and that is obesity motivating most of
the founders that I have spent a lot of
time with that have gone on to be super
successful spent a very long time
on their idea when a lot of other people
would have given up and either people
said it sucks or people said nothing at
all and a framework that I have for when
to go up and when to keep working is it
should be an internal not external
decision if people aren't using it or
people are saying it's bad that alone is
not a reason to give up you want to pay
some attention to that they might be
right
but I think the best entrepreneurs I
know they make an internal decision
about when to give up or when to keep
working on something it's basically when
you have run out of ideas and something
is not working then it's a good time to
stop startups to be success will have to
build something people want if you get
that right you can get everything what's
wrong pretty much if you get that wrong
you can get everything else perfect and
we see this all the time we start ups
that hire the best lawyer in the valley
they get a beautiful office they they
work with really great accountants and a
great PR firm they do everything that it
started needs to do except build a
product that customers or users one and
this is so important this is this is
probably the most important piece of
startup a device in the early days this
is the only thing that matters you have
to do this you can ignore all the other
advice you can ignore all of the crazy
stuff that people do when they're trying
to advise me about a set of a company in
fact you should ignore most advice most
of the rice is terrible you should feel
free to ignore any with this - except
this one thing if the start-up doesn't
make something the users want the
startup will never ever be successful I
think in general you you really should
try to live your life without regrets
and if you and if you are really set on
starting a particular company even if
you know that you could go be employee
number 30 at Airbnb and everybody is
already going like this and you'd have
more of an impact but you're going to
regret for the rest of your life not
starting this particular company because
you're still in love with it you might
decide to do that however I think this
other thing like making an impact on
whatever you do is sort of the
satisfying thing in life in professional
life and so I think most people find
that their job satisfaction like goes up
with with the impact they have on their
company or the world or whatever and if
you start a company that is you know a
mild success or join a company that's a
huge success you probably have more of
an impact in the latter case I think
people have terrible risk calculus in
general even people who try to be really
good about this or
the answer I think is almost always a
you're wrong about what is risking what
it's not risky and B most people don't
take enough risk especially early in
your career being um young and unknown
and poor that is actually a great gift
in terms of the amount of risk you can
take and I think people don't capitalize
not enough I think what risk actually
looks like is not doing something that
you will then spend the rest of your
life regretting and it's a quote you
have people regret way more the things
they didn't do them things that they did
do so if you really believe in something
there's an idea that you're super
passionate about um you know and you
take a calculated risk to start a
company realizing you may forego a
couple of years of studying come in on
our job and whatever else and you know
maybe people call you a failure or
whatever that's a great risk to take and
if you don't take that risk I think
you'll a very high chance that you end
up regretting that I think the wrong
kind of risk to take is where people
don't actually do things or don't commit
something because they don't want to
fail and they over rate the risk of
failure in the reputation damage or
embarrassment or whatever I think one
really important thing to strive for in
your career is to be a doer not a talker
and the reason that people don't do
stuff one is it's hard and two is it's
risky and so you have these people that
you know want to dabble on a bunch of
different projects but never be all in
on one and I think it's a combination of
work and risk and it's you know I think
that's really bad I think history
belongs to the doers and I think you
should take a risk actually do something
don't just sit around and talk and
organize and bring together groups and
go to solve leadership conferences and
whatever it is these people spend their
time on other than actually building
something and just take the risk of
committing to what you you have
conviction on team problems are the
biggest killer of start up inside of YC
everyone thinks that you know startups
dive at the
of competitors but startups commit
suicide much more often than startups
get get killed by somebody else if you
don't have a good team eventually the
startup will implode and if you do have
a great team the startup will just go on
to do better and other things so there
are a number of jobs that the CEO has
but hiring I think is the most important
if you don't hire really well your
company will never be a big success as
your company gets bigger and bigger the
only thing the CEO gets to decide on is
the company strategy and who the players
are who the people are everything else
gets done by other people so you have to
hire incredibly well you have to spend
like a third of your time hiring people
and recruiting the best people in the
world even still at YC this is the
biggest part of my job you know I can't
advise every startup but I can make sure
we got the best partners in the world
and then if you make a mistake hiring it
fix it incredibly quickly most founders
understand that it's important to hire
really well and most founders prioritize
that but it's also important to fire
people quickly that aren't sort of a
members of the team and most founders
don't understand this or they understand
it but it's still painful they don't
want to do it one of the things that
someone once told me was most impressive
about Mark Zuckerberg is not that he
hired pretty well because a lot of
founders do that but that he fired well
and he could fire people quickly they
weren't working out and it's just really
hard to learn how to do with the founder
losing focus is another way that
founders get off track I actually think
this is a symptom of burnout when you
get really burned out on running the
business you want to do easier things or
sort of more gratifying things you want
to go to conferences and have people
tell you how great you are you know you
want to do all these things that are not
actually building the business and the
most common post YC failure case for the
companies we fund is that they're
incredibly focused during YC on their
company and then after they start doing
a lot of other things you know they they
advise companies they go to conferences
whatever focus is what made you
successful in the first place
there are a lot of reasons people lose
focus
but fight against that really really
hard here's one really important which
is the evil bit mortgages of the time
and when the founders of Airbnb first
Kendra they were delighted to have two
users and if you told them that Sunday
they're going to be running an email if
we going back on tonight other point be
no more of my friends as such and they
will be able to let this up and said
you're crazy like really don't work with
me because you know you're talking about
on so these are just like pressure in
the last couple of years to have an
immediate vision about how you're going
to have this you know time undergoing
about companies and no one honestly has
that in there in that birthday Google
almost education some million dollars um
they do have it's like to offer cancer
you know like the like what it was very
very hopeful Facebook you guys are
billion dollar so um it's okay alike
become one which is as we build in fact
that's what should happen so what we
look for is people that have the kernel
of an idea that either you can develop
independent reach but you can't click on
that right away
you have to focus on delivering
something great for a small undefeated
surface but when we talk about this is
that you know there's like you can
either is create an initial class that a
lot of users really like or this moment
that you can really love obviously you'd
like to make something that a lot of
users really love with a lie be
activated by big companies you can
Cleveland so you don't have to have a
particular the world plan on day one in
fact very feels a company that we've
been involved with is gone to do it
thought they were going to initially
they just the founder has something
they're really talking about that had a
plan about listening
they had one defensibility a certain
building hmm
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kevin asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
it's sensei that has the biggest impact
on you and why what are you going to
take from this video and immediately
apply it somehow to your life or to your
business leave it down in the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout-out to emolia's design thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and making that tribute
picture to it as well I really really
appreciate your support so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon
yeah and I think people also seem to
have sort of this fear of being told no
a lot and not asking for what they want
I'm sure that's something that you've
encountered with people yeah this was
one of the other things I learned but I
wish I had gotten advice on early in my
career is ask for what you want you will
get told no a lot but sometimes it will
work and and I think you see a lot of
entrepreneurs shoot themselves in the
foot because they don't ask that person
to quit a job and come join them they
don't ask this big company to do a deal
with them and they're just not
aggressive enough and I think you being
willing to ask what you want and and be
somewhat aggressive are really important
characteristics of being an entrepreneur
people don't want to fail they don't
want to be told no they don't want to
end up in some crisis how to keep track
productivity systems so the one I use
which I actually of course really well
is I keep one piece of paper with my
goals for sort of a three to twelve
month time frame and I look at that
everyday and then separately I keep one
one page for every day of my short term
goals for that day and so if I need to
do something in like a week I just flip
forward seven pages and write it down
and then I also keep a list of every
person and what they're working on and
what I tell them and when I talked to
them about what we talked about last
time so every time I sit down with
someone I kind of have the full state
and a list of things for that person
that works really well in addition to
being a person of people there are few
other things that the US and other um
this would make a culture
I want momentum they annoy me in the
people name and
that going to pick out the bone studies
and under completing and so one of the
most important jobs event here is to
make sure a company met especially
because if you know if they just cook
there's a lot about whole and if you
keep that going it's this sort of this
keep on going you know just is ongoing
Helen on the other thing that we see is
sort of the the missionary mercenary
device I think most cultures end up
being either a mercenary cultural
missionary culture and the great
companies are all the missionary
cultures if you believe in the mission
if you are sufficiently ambitious if you
prevent people yes we're going to make a
big impact when we're going to reach
these people looking to support and
clean is going you can great for the
world that's what motivates the best
people and if you have a culture like
that there where you do have the English
is important thing it's easier to
motivate people in many ways it is
easier to start a hard company than it
is Department easy company more people
will be excited you have a better
culture if it being some of the matters
if you're doing big things if you have a
kind of culture where you're telling
people like you need to get into your
desk at Miami good mind if you work with
all by the bays but people might do that
for a little oil on that is but it
almost never affect that's just said
it's not why I have ever seen to be
clear results